morning okay well you can see the picket
line is in place uh outside bristol
temple mead station already this morning
uh the figure of the number of trains
running here reflects that national
image eighty percent of uh services
cancelled here at temple means this is
of course the major junction for trains
in the south west uh you change here to
go west to wales north up to birmingham
south down
to devon and of course to london there
are a limited number of services running
here five services some to london some
to cardiff some to taunton and plymouth
in devon and westbury in wiltshire but
the figures that we've just been handed
in the last couple of minutes show that
football
on tuesday's strike was uh down by 70
so a real impact clearly here at the
station as many people are having to
work from home there's no rail
replacement as such so people having to
make alternative arrangements
glastonbury started yesterday as we all
saw many people struggling to get down
to the festival there may be a few late
comers trying to get their way
down to the festival here but as i say
the furthest south you can get from
bristol today is plymouth in devon right
on the cornish border for absolutely no
trains at all running in cornwall
throughout these strike days that whole
county completely cut off people having
to make alternative arrangements we are
expecting a few people to start rocking
up for those early services running here
at bristol temple meads but you can see
the workers behind me here getting
plenty of honks and support from drivers
going past here as the second day of
strikes gets underway
um
thank you fraser morning to you as well
situation there
morning okay well no picket lines here
at chester railway station but no
passengers either down there mentioning
a 20
service that's operating from bristol
and the 20 figure that we keep hearing
about
the level of of trains available is
countrywide it's not in places like
chester smaller places like this that
rely on more local services rather than
on the mainline networks
are closed all together and that's been
a real problem for many of the family of
the traders here we'll be talking later
on this morning to one uh store owner
who's saying that it's created a massive
drop in business and they are bracing
themselves for saturday normally their
busiest day and the day of the third
planned uh strike actions so it's
unlikely that the talks aren't going to
wrap up quickly enough in order to to
prevent
any strike action on uh on saturday we
were hearing um yesterday that uh if if
an agreement had been made yesterday
during the talks that that was going to
be too late to prevent strike action
today because timetables and so on were
already in place and that looks as
though it's going to be the case for
saturday as well and i think a lot of
places that rely on rail services that
are now effectively cut off during these
days of rail strikes will be looking
pretty nervously towards the summer in
the hope that this situation can be
resolved before further strikes are
called uh for later on in the summer
people have been able to find
alternatives i know the department of
transport was saying yesterday that the
strike hadn't had the impact that maybe
the unions had been hoping for but uh an
impact in terms of people finding
alternatives is still an impact there
are still tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands of people who've had to change
their plans during these uh during the
strike days and during the other days
this week when there's been disruptions
which have been caused by the knock-on
effects of the strike days so saying
that there's no impact uh whatsoever or
reduced impact i think is is perhaps not
necessarily the case people have been
trying to find alternatives we have got
used to working from home and lots of
people have been doing that i know down
there mentioned that some of the figures
in terms of football in footfall in
places like bristol are down but there
have been reports that some of the data
suggesting that football in smaller
market towns and so on has actually gone
up as a result of people working from
home and going into the local town
centre to buy their cups of coffee or to
have lunch or whatever so football in
some instances has increased slightly
only slightly and only in
small market towns as a result of the
strike action but i think what's
interesting is throughout the uh
throughout the whole uh timeline of this
uh event from the initial vote that had
taken place by uh the rmt members uh to
to go for strike action and then the
announcement of the dates of the strike
action and now that the strikes have
actually started the commuters and
passengers that i've been speaking to
still broadly support the strike action
saying that if that's what they need to
do in order to get a reasonable
reasonable wage then that's what they
need to do okay gentlemen thanks for the
update much appreciated